hi I'm dancing a technical account
manager on the Android partner
engineering team and today I'm here to
talk to you about how to maximize your
apps reach by designing for devices with
large this place this is the first of a
series of episodes and today we'll focus
on in different input methods as you
know the intro ecosystem continues to
grow more and more unique form factors
are coming onto the market providing a
connected continuum to name a few
there's already smart TVs set up boxes
and we're also starting to see in the
pipeline these android pc sticks all in
one smart monitors and of course our own
google TV which announced the i/o this
year that they're migrating to stock
jelly bean android later this year now
these devices typically provide not
touch input methods such as joysticks
trackpads d-pads optical mice etc now
the Android platform provides facilities
for developers to target these new use
cases and that's what we want to
highlight today now these new form
factors like smart TVs typically
designed for living room and provide the
template viewing experience in other
words the non-touch you are in the new
jelly bean mr2 CDD we have a new
definition for the fake touch input
which is basically a alternative to the
conventional direct touch interface and
provides support for point and click
drag and drop functionalities from a
distance developers should improve their
UX for fake touch devices again the
android framework provides a set of AP
is to help you define and collect these
input events we've listed to fill them
here we encourage you to read through
these CDD definitions in frame or KPIs
to understand how to take advantage of
this implemented
now in this simple table we listed
changes you should make to support the
non chose you I in your Android manifest
all you need to do is make sure to
remove the touch feature requirement
unless it's absolutely necessary for
your app and you should consider faith
touch as an alternative that provides
more functionality than the traditional
non touch inputs such as Deepak and
provide now let's quickly look at a demo
to simplify things we're using a nexus
10 here with a USB mouse to emulate the
fig touch input this way we can work
around the Play Store filtering for
those apps that I have not yet declared
effective support so here we'll have my
favorite variation of angry bird game
the star wars edition let's continue a
game that has started so as you can see
you can perform just about any
functionalities you would with a full
touch you I you know I wasn't very good
first try but let me try again so you
know you could just bring the birds away
using your your fake touch inputs but I
should mention here you're not able to
perform multi-touch gestures in this
setup because I'm using a simple mouse
but with devices that support multitouch
trackpad or pointers your way we will be
able to support these gestures such as
Jimmy in the zoo meow so there you go
please look into fake touch so now let's
look at making your apps more d-pad
friendly now deeper has been around a
long time even in some of the original
smartphones they were building and
almost in all remotes and obviously USB
keyboards so the reason we still want to
look at d-pad is that even with this new
CD d definition some of the existing
devices still may not support faked
hardship for some time and even with the
fake touch capable devices it is often
more effective and easier for users to
operate remotes using this d-pad
in the living room environment apps to
support respect all standard key events
for basic navigation so harshly actually
optimize now one thing we should focus
on foremost is to address the focus
handling basically you want to make a
conscious decision where to place the
default focus to minimize key prices the
concept is simple we shouldn't always
assume users can randomly select a area
on your page using touch so we should
utilize these api is listed here to
request default focus for certain
elements or explicitly take over control
for the focus sequence to traverse your
pages another optimization tip is to
actually change your layout to be more
deeper friendly this is also not a new
concept and many apps designed for
tablets have already adapted to this
approach but again the idea here is to
minimize number of key prices user 1
user tries to traverse through the page
in a non touch UI in this case you can
jump forward in the tabs by traversing
just left or right on the screen which
is much faster than scrolling all the
way up or down through the page using a
d-pad input again to illustrate the
relationships between these three
implemented we've added deeper entry in
this table if your app is fully d-pad
friendly in other words you can
completely navigate throughout your app
by using just the conventional d-pad and
don't have to use any gesture control
etc then you can simply define declare
just no touch or touch equals false in
your Android manifest and you may not
need to consider fake touch but going
back to the previous example are angry
birds that app is actually a good
candidate for using this new fake touch
definition so now let's do a quick demo
this time let's look at a Google service
to play movies app also one of my
favorite I should mention that this app
has made a lot of improvements
in the last release to support d-pad and
as you see here in a second so now I've
switched to a USB keyboard and you can
see I'm able to traverse sequentially
through out the app by changing the
focus on the top and selecting a content
I wish to watch control playback
actually selective on key there you go
so the movie started so Escape key would
take me back one level as you would
expect just like a touch input so this
is why we call a d-pad friendly
application so that's all I have for you
today please stay tuned for our next
episode and thanks for listening